[Music]
second game of the new speed run
we are playing classical openings all
the way through
around 12 1300 that's going to be the
new wrinkle
and by that i mean we're essentially not
playing gambits
we are going to play
openings that i recommend to beginners
so
1396 wow we actually get a pretty high
rated opponent that's fine with me i
mean i i don't really mind that
we don't have to play only beginners all
the time
so let's go e4 e5
and okay so this is called the bishop's
opening it is intimidating to many
people
and
obviously it's it's the opening where
white develops the bishop first now the
way that black
should react to this is no different
than how you play against the vienna for
example since white didn't go knight f3
we don't need to start with knight c6 we
can start with knight f6
and exploit the fact that white has not
gone knight f3 d3
and now again
many possible
um
many possible schemes of development
here
but you know there's a line with c6
which i'm not going to play
the simplest is just to develop the
other knight with knight c6
and after knight f3 we've transposed
into an italian so
with the move bishop c5 we transpose
into a full italian we can also play the
move bishop e7 here which is a slightly
more passive
developing move but also perfectly
viable since we're trying to play very
solid i'm going to play bishop e7
and
you know
hopefully we're going to get a little
practice in
you know playing out these dry positions
okay so we can go d6 we can castle it
really doesn't matter
the order in which we do things here
let's go d6 and then castle
castles
yeah this is the hungarian variation it
is quite passive but extremely solid we
have no weaknesses
the position is relatively symmetrical
with the exception of
you know white's bishops being
marginally better placed but
we're going to try to neutralize that
i'm not assuming that okay there should
be three so how should we play here
we obviously have one undeveloped piece
left
are we would we be justified in playing
bishop e6 is this trade something to
fear for black
if you've listened to the previous speed
runs you know the answer to that
question in italian positions the
opening of the f-file is generally good
for the side that controls it for whom
the f-file opens even if it means
doubling your pawns
so bishop b6 is rarely
a move that you should refrain from
playing based on bishop take c6 that's
never dangerous
although we have doubled pawns in the
center that pawn on e6 will control
important squares as well
as well as the pawn on e5
and we're going to have free pressure
down the f-file
the other advantage of developing the
bishop to e6 is that is that if white
doesn't respond if white continues the
standoff
we don't have to take on c4 we can
actually
break through in the center with the
move d5
gaining space for our pieces so it's
kind of a tough situation for white
uh to figure out what to do and he takes
it okay i like it
and we take and now i already like
black's position here
now one additional comment i'll make
here is that
white is not castled yet we need to
we need to be prepared for white
castling in either direction
thank you super palace
we need to be prepared for white
castling in either direction
uh just putting that out there
how should we proceed here we've got
many good approaches
many good approaches
um one good move is for example to play
queen e8
uh
perhaps aiming to bring the queen to g6
in the event that he castles short
we can also play more ambitiously we can
play a move like a6 to prepare a pawn
storm if he castles queenside if he
castles kingside then a6 is still a
helpful move
we can also go d5 that to me that is
probably what i would play over the
board but again i want to continue
playing very solid style
uh for the purposes of the early part of
the speed run so let's stick with the
move the flexible move a6
again why first of all this is just a
helpful move in general it's not going
to hurt not going to hurt to control the
b5 square but if he castles queen side
then we can jump start our pawn storm
with the move b5
okay if white castle's short then we're
going to have clear ways of pressuring
him down the file
yeah a5 would weaken the b5 square
so
if i would i will answer this after the
game but
a5 is a little too weakening in this
position
okay g4
uh that's a blunder thunder's a pawn
who can tell me
actually this is quite an instructive
mode because we have two ways to win the
pawn immediately you should notice
i've primed you to look at the file the
knight on f3 is left undefended this
screams discovery tactic
there are two of them knight takes g4
knight takes e4 let's use our logic
after knight takes g4 pawn takes g4
we've opened up the h file for him
given that white is probably going to
castle queenside doesn't seem very
advisable so much better idea is to take
the center pawn
because it's the center pawn but also
because we don't open any avenues on the
king side for him
this is easy to calculate he takes it we
take the knight on f3
it would be a good idea to make sure
that your rook doesn't get trapped
somehow in f3 but since we have the
whole f file we have nothing to fear
and we're going to be
up upon here
and
after any such pond trade quickly we ask
ourselves how has the position changed
what new ideas can we try to apply
one idea that has become quite a bit
stronger
with the absence of the epon just
thinking logically is what what idea
seems a lot more attractive now that the
e pawn is gone
just put the put the dots together
well yeah the move d5 looks
looks extremely appealing because it
sends the knight back then perhaps we
have d4 that bishop on e3 might get
trapped
so our eyes are already on the move d5
that's going to be our default reaction
bishop g5
okay so d5 still looks very good here
what's going to happen is he's going to
take the bishop we're going to take with
the queen we're going to chase the
knight out of the center
i see absolutely no reason to refrain
from this move
takes takes then we're going to bring
the other rook to f8
it's already very depressing for white
knight d4 was also great yeah okay he
takes it
take obviously with the queen
i guess this is gonna go knight g5
which is going to further exacerbate the
situation
well how well i would love to reroute
the knight to f4 but it's very very hard
to do
i just don't see a path because e6 is
blocked by a pawn otherwise we could try
going like this
knight shoe five so where should we go
with the rook
an instructive moment here a lot of
people default to going rook f8 but
don't rush to bring the rook back
don't rush to bring your pieces all the
way back
if you notice the fact that the queen
defends the knight our queen pressures
the knight the move rookout force slices
off the connection
that knight is simply trapped he's got
to go h4 that gives up another pawn
and white's position
essentially collapses
now if he goes h4 we have another
interesting moment to talk about
okay so
uh dr x max easy actually makes a very
good point
there's a couple of ways we could play
this the obvious move is rook takes g4
now some of you are presenting a valid
counterpoint which is that rook takes g4
opens up the g file
after rook g4 he is likely to castle
then maybe he gets a rook on you want to
get some sort of counter play
unlikely that just the g file alone is
going to give white sufficient counter
play for the two pawns
but an idea would be to play h6 first
kick the knight away to hp then take on
g4 that seems to
dull
white's any potential kingside
initiative but we also have a third
approach
we don't have to touch any of this at
all we can play moves such as knight d4
or even more incisive is rook a to f8
knight t4 is not going anywhere
knight d4 also doesn't threaten anything
which bothers me a little bit
because this square is protected by
white's knight knight d4 he can play c3
don't rush to bring our pieces to
central squares
this move creates a big threat of rook
takes f2
forces him to commit further and then
we're going to decide
hopefully the logic makes sense here
now all of these moves are good h6 is
good rook takes g4 is good knight t4 is
good in many of these positions as i
often say
don't bog yourself down trying to figure
out why one particular move is better
than the others oftentimes it's going to
be two or three valid alternatives
as it is here so if you guys are asking
why didn't we play x it might just be
more or less random or a matter of taste
so i'll explain why it's a threat it's
not just two rooks for the queen if you
calculate further than that you'll see
that we win a bunch of pawns on top of
it
first of all it's two rooks for
a queen and a pawn and we're already up
a pawn so it's gonna be two pawns
but if you think about the position
after take stakes take stakes we have a
fork in that position who sees it
while he's thinking i can answer the
question
yeah queen c5 check
and then we take c2 this is a common
thing a queen fork at the end of a line
there's a very famous game that features
a similar type of idea
c4
okay so this move does a whole lot of
bad
first of all it permanently weakens the
d4 square
and so now i love the idea of just
slamming the knight into d4 we can still
play rook takes f2 nothing wrong with
that
but now i feel like we can squeeze
a lot more out of the position just by
bringing our pieces to dominant squares
and of course pawns don't go backwards
so he can never chase us away from d4
now we're threatening h6 followed by
knight f3 with a fork
no so queen takes g5 is is obviously a
decent transition to a winning end game
but remember what you're playing for
you're playing to win
it's a much more economical way to chase
the night away with move h6
so don't be fancy just to force
liquidation try to find
the nicest you know the most efficient
way to win
i mean this is like a model position
white has no moves
we play to win the game right exactly
if he castles we take f2
with uh devastating second rank attack
yeah i like how we have just upon an a6
from from past life
okay rook h3
this doesn't substantively change
anything we can still go h6 in fact the
knight is now simply trapped
what that which is kind of funny
yeah i think this might be resigns
no that wasn't kasparov
maybe we eat you know
it wasn't it wasn't because we know 866
so obviously you know we want to um to
keep the knight on on on d4 and and and
and um
i mean
you're resigning heroes is is very uh
very good option
you know
i remember you knew when i played in a
corporate in
seville you know 1994 right
it's um the match was a match match went
pretty well for me but corporal he am
always going to resign late
all right takes takes d5
we can take g4 we can take d5 it
absolutely doesn't matter as long as
you're taking something let's take g4
that just seems more incisive it hits
the rook
and if he goes richie through we have a
nice tactic to finish finish off the
game
okay yeah you guys are already seeing it
what's important is that the knight is
taking away the square from the king we
have the second ingredient the doubled
rooks and queen takes g3 ends of the
game rook f1 is checkmate
and
you know if you're a beginner somewhere
out in the chat and saying well how did
you see that quickly
that's oh ten bucks from leopard tip
penguin okay he castles let's just take
on f2 we could have taken to the rook
but
this simplifies the position
how did i see that so quickly
well uh that's where puzzles come in
that's where you pull yourself up by the
bootstraps so with
with just endless puzzle solving at the
beginning of your your chest development
that's the great
technique
and and then you'll just find that you
find these moves even without knowing
how you found them you're just gonna
notice it and that's how pattern
recognition works relatively easy game
not a lot to talk about there's just one
thing i wanted to explain
which is the question of why okay so
first of all yeah but should be 76
this is all normal
okay so just to reiterate a lot of times
you'll see people going bishop b3
and then the move d5 is very powerful
particularly because he's placed his two
minors awkwardly and d4 is now a fork
threat and in the event
of a trade on d5 black just has a great
position
okay so bishop takes f takes queen d2
why not a5 because after a4
i feel like
remember we have to
allow the potential of attacking on the
queen side i feel like now if white
castles queen side
black is going to have a much harder
time opening up the queen side so i just
don't see the point of locking
everything up so quickly
i feel like a6 is more flexible d5 i
mentioned as a possible move
and here white should probably respond
with bishop g5
i was a little bit concerned that my e5
pawn was going to become a little bit
weak
so so i didn't you know i didn't want to
commit to anything d5 isn't really going
anywhere
and uh i think a6 a6
is an annoying move to face
now
g4 was almost a decisive mistake
but had he castled short there's a
couple of techniques for attacking the
king side here
and the two main ones are queen e8 queen
g6
and the knight coming to h5 and usually
these ideas are are in conjunction with
each other because once you get the
queen to g6 you're going to threaten
rook takes f3 and the knight can come
out to f4
and i i love these positions for black
this is the kind of position i beat
wesley in
and aim chess i feel like black just
gets
really nice attacking chances here so
that's partially why
opening up the f file like this is good
for black
one thing you got to be a little bit
careful about is a move like nice u5
some in some positions this could be
nasty here it doesn't give anything due
to queen d7
and in some positions you'll have this
as a follow-up move obviously here it's
about this gambit
okay so i think the rest after g4 was
pretty self-explanatory d5
rook out for slicing off the queen that
technique of
of slicing the connection between two
pieces with another piece
is important not rushing to take pawns
especially when they
give your opponent some life
and instead focusing on bringing all of
the pieces to ideal squares this kind of
patience to realize the pawns are not
going anywhere why its position is way
too broken to defend any of the pawns
so we
start by getting everything to proper
squares then the wind kind of presents
itself all right
so that's where we're gonna end for
today guys hope you enjoyed the speedrun
game
we'll see you guys later thank you so
much
hope you enjoyed hanging out good night
everybody
[Music]
you